In the last few modules, we've talked about all the different components that we have within
a system.
Now let's talk about some of the significant vulnerabilities.
In the last few modules, we've talked about all the different components that we have
within a system.
Now let's talk about some of the significant vulnerabilities that we have in systems.
So here's a list of some of the major architectural risks that exist in systems, things like single
points of failures and bypass controls and race conditions.
We'll go through each of these and we'll talk about what the risk is or what the vulnerability
is and in most cases how you would go about mitigating that vulnerability.
Let's start with this concept of a single point of failure.
So what is a single point of failure?
Well a single point of failure is where you've got a single system or process that if it
goes down, everything goes down.
So in this little diagram that we have here, we've got the sketchy internet at the very
top there.
We've got the traffic coming in from the internet going through a firewall and then through
a router down to our little happy systems in our trusted internal network.
You don't have a trusted network.
We'll talk with that later.
So what are the single points of failure in this diagram here?
Well there's two.
Our firewall and our router are both single points of failure.
So how do we address the risks of single points of failure?
Well, it's through redundancy or having multiple systems and in this diagram here you can
see we don't just have one firewall and one router.
We have two firewalls and two routers and we have them interconnected.
So if one router goes down or one firewall goes down, the traffic is just routed around.
So that's how we reduce the risk of single points of failure.
Next, let's talk about bypass controls.
Now before I explain exactly what a bypass control is, let me tell you a story and I think
this will all make sense, okay?
So let's say I'm a network administrator and I've just bought some wicked new firewall.
It's like a million dollar firewall and being the very security conscious network administrator
that I am.
When this firewall gets delivered in the morning, I type in as my first task, I type in
some super strong 50 character password for the root account so that it's a very secure
firewall and you know, that was a big job.
So I go off and have lunch and then I come back from lunch and I type in the super secure
50 character password and correct password, crap.
I type it in again, I type it in another time, oh, I've just forgotten the password to
the million dollar firewall.
What do I do now?
Do I take the million dollar firewall and just throw it in the garbage because I mean,
this is the root account without access to this account.
You can't configure this firewall.
So what do you do?
Well, you get out a paperclip, you bend it open and walk up to the back of the firewall,
find a little pinhole in the back, hold the paperclip in there for about 10 seconds and
what happens?
The firewall configuration resets.
This is a perfect example of a bypass control.
So in the diagram that I'm showing you here, our regular control is that a user would
log into a system with a password.
But let's say the user has forgotten their password.
We want to implement a bypass control.
So bypass controls are controls that we intentionally build into a system to allow us to bypass some
primary mechanism, like say the authentication mechanism.
So we very clear on this wording, bypass controls are intentional.
They're intentionally built into a system.
Do they introduce additional risks?
Of course they do.
And this example that I just gave you with the million dollar firewall, if someone was
able to get physical access to that firewall, they could reset the firewall.
And there are lots and lots of examples of bypass controls out there.
And all of them, whenever you implement a bypass control, it introduces additional risk.
So how do we reduce the risk of bypass controls?
Well, you've got to implement the appropriate mitigating controls, whatever those happen
to be.
In the example of a firewall, it would be physical security.
As long as you prevent someone an unauthorized person from getting physical access to the
firewall, they can't reset the firewall.
So whatever is the appropriate mitigating control, you put that in place to reduce the
risk of any new risk you've implemented with a bypass control.
And now let's talk about these six letters here, TOC, TOU, TalkTow.
What do they stand for?
Well, TOC, time of check and TOU, time of use.
What this refers to is often also referred to as a race condition.
And let me tell you another story to explain this one.
So let's say I walk into work in the morning, I get my laptop out, plug it in, and type
in my username and password and log into the system.
And just as I log in, someone from HR comes and says, Rob, kind of please see you in my
office.
And I say, yeah, sure, no problem.
We walk right over to their office, and they sit me down and say, and they say, Rob,
you're a terrible employee, we're firing you.
And I think my response would probably be like, yeah, I get it, I'm a pretty horrible
person.
I'm on the same page.
I get it.
No worries.
So it's a very quick discussion.
And I leave to the HR person's office, and I'm back at my desk in like three minutes.
What do I find when I'm back at my desk?
Well, I may well find that my laptop is still logged in.
My screensaver might not be set to time out for, say, five minutes.
So if I'm back at my laptop, and I'm able to access that laptop, should I be able to?
And of course not.
I've just been fired.
This is a perfect example of time of check, time of use, or a race condition.
The idea is if an attacker can race in and get access to and use a system before there's
the next check, they might be able to do something that they're not supposed to.
They might be able to hijack the session as an example.
So how do we reduce the risk of time of check, time of use, or race conditions?
Well, you have to increase the frequency of reauthentication.
So in the example I gave of coming back to my laptop, if the screensaver password had
come up after even just one minute, then I wouldn't have had unauthorized access to
that system.
So the way we do deal with the risk of time of check, time of use is increase the frequency
of reauthentication.
The next vulnerability we're going to talk about is emanations.
Now let's start with an definition.
What does emanations mean?
Well, computer systems emanate all sorts of different stuff.
They emanate light from the screen.
They emanate sounds.
They emanate radio waves and some of them are intentional, things like our Wi-Fi.
Our magnetic hard drives when they're being used emanate magnetic waves.
There's all sorts of stuff that our systems emanate.
And the risk with emanations is that someone may be able to detect those emanations and
gather information that they're not supposed to from those emanations.
Now there's three major ways that we can deal with the risk of emanations.
The first is shielding.
So what this means is you put some sort of shield around the device that blocks electromagnetic
waves.
An example of shielding is something known as tempest.
And you should remember this.
So tempest is a tech suite of technologies developed by the Royal Military to protect their
planes and tanks and things like that from the rescues or whomever, from the bad guys
whoever those happen to be.
So one of the ways that we prevent reduce the risk of emanations is shielding.
The next is white noise.
What is white noise?
Static random noise.
And the idea behind white noise is that if you blast a really strong signal of random
noise, whatever small weak emanations might be coming out of your system will be overwhelmed
by the random noise, preventing the attacker from listening in and gathering data from
your system.
The final major way that we can deal with the risk of emanations is what are known as control
zones.
Think of this as physical security.
Control zones simply means that if someone isn't able to get close enough to your system
that's emanating these weak signals, then they're not going to be able to pick them up.
And so this is why in the movies, the super security government system is always buried
in some bunker underground inside of a mountain.
And the only way to get through getting near it is to hire Tom Cruise to repel out of
the vents in the ceiling or something like that.
So control zones, control physical access to the device to reduce the risk of emanations.